so I saw this article came out a couple
days ago yeah what it say and uh these
are four social media influencers who
were swept up by the movement that
claims that obesity is perfectly healthy
body positivity and The Tragic Truth is
that they've all died under the age of
45 Britney sewer is one of those people
I'm out of breath
constantly um you know and I wish I knew
the cost of eating I wish need the cost
of the the Comfort at the time that I
was
seeking um um and I just want this to be
a warning to other people that just need
to hear the hard truth you know that if
you if you keep it up and you keep you
know gaining and not taking care of
yourself and moving around and doing
what you need to do you know your health
is going to decline possibly you know
it's this is my experience but you know
my health declined you know I can
I do what I need to do you know to take
care of my husband and stuff still and I
make things work and I can do the things
that I need to do but they're very very
hard um you know I had to have help
trimming my toenails the other day
because I felt so out of breath trying
to lean over and do my
toes um there's just a lot that is taken
away from me and I want you to know that
it's not worth it
food's not worth your life and uh I
really hope that I could turn it around
this time because
it's it's really scary how bad things
can get I was truly okay with dying I I
accepted it that it was just this is
just how it was going to go I was going
to eat myself until it just it all went
away one day I realized I can't give up
I I cannot there is too much writing on
me being able to do this and I have so
many people that need me here and I
cannot let the things that have happened
be the reason why it's the end for me
and feel sometimes like um you know they
ask like why do you get upset when you
see this kind of stuff and I say the
same thing every time it's like to me
more than anything this just said
it's not even a condemnation thing you
would never see me going up somebody
who's obese or trying to fix their life
or whatever or even just living the life
and be like say something I would never
say nothing you know but when people get
online and glorify that's when it just
upsets me it upsets me cuz I've seen
people who had a lot to offer their
communities and their families past see
the sadness in their eyes when they got
to deal with that high blood pressure
and how much it negatively impacts them
so it's just like some people are like
oh yeah you deserve it whatever I have
none of that in my heart honestly
watching that girl and hearing the fear
in her voice all I felt was sad for her
that's it I felt sad and now she's dead
and her loved ones the people that she
was they all have to deal with that so
the reality is we're just dealing with a
a huge tragedy that's expanding more and
more so this guy here tick tocker Tik
Tok star waffler 69 died of a presumed
heart attack according to his brother
real name Taylor lean he did not flaunt
his weight but amassed 1.9 million
followers by posting videos reviewing
Bizarre Foods including reind meat and
thinned ham from the 1960s his last
video was posted a day before he died
showing him eating a giant Fruit Loop in
milk the famed foodie whose real name is
Taylor died on Wednesday night his
brother Clayton announced the sad news
in a Tik Tok video he has passed away
from a presumed heart
attack Jim Lopez who sted in the reality
TV show super siiz Salon died from heart
complications age
37 so a lot of people been talking about
so the article I sent you article oh
yeah I saw that I saw you I saw uh
what's your girl's
name comment on it yeah your girl um who
yeah your girl's name there n see your
smile say about to say some
careful what's her name yeah yeah n no
we're not doing that the the trans girl
hey don't clim me don't play me what's
her name why you say it's my girl oh
Blair White you saying that it's your
girl you're the one that discovered her
you knew about her before I knew her so
it's your girl like like Destiny's your
girl cuz you know her before I do no
that's she's actually my friend we spend
time together why would you say Blair
wse is my girl I've never spoken to her
I've never even talk to her about never
you never spoke to BL white yo you are
doing some weird stuff right now I'm
just kidding bro her Li okay okay so
when you do it it's jokes when I do it
it's not jokes out of here
inating I have relationship with people
I don't and then they don't understand I
just say so they they about to start yo
y when did AB start talking and then
it's going to start you don't understand
that's what you do n that's not what I
do I do the same thing that you do what
I do whatever a whole bunch of go
ahead I always do go ahead you don't
know what I you in give examples no I
don't need to give you examples you know
that's not how it works when you ask
people to bring receipts all of a sudden
they just want to be like I'm loyal
customer excuse me no that's a good one
excuse me that's a good one where am I
where's the receipt at you don't get you
ask people for receipt I listen to like
I'm a lawyer
bars I know cuz I do
that I know you do I I've been shopping
here you know me stepen you know me my
name is Dave yeah St I've been here and
I bought this from you there are a lot
of lies
that modern progressivism tells right
and unfortunately because a large chunk
of the population is Stuck on Stupid
they do believe that no matter how
obviously deceptive and insane the lies
are a lot of people believe them I
consider one of the most damaging lies
that is told by The Establishment is
that you can be healthy at any size that
you can be obese and somehow happy and
that lie has spawned the absolutely is
movement fat positivity and I am
100% glorifying obesity and there's
nothing you can do about it it's ironic
right that it's called the fat
positivity
movement because they're not
moving
because that's a wild that one got me
I'm not going to lie that one got
me I don't know where she got that from
or if she wrote that herself but that
one was
wild okay I was was I was not expecting
a jab I thought you say there's nothing
positive about
it she went to the other word and I
didn't even see that one coming there we
go she got me off guard his Tik Tok has
really taken the reins and has
popularized it and taken it to this
over-the-top level of exposure we get to
see these people documenting their
Journeys their fat Journeys and what
you're starting to see is these people
are dying literally famous influencers
within this movement are passing away
very young I ruined my life with
food um binge eating and lack of
self-care um and I'm hoping that
it's not too late for me this time um
you know I ain't been to the store in 2
years
maybe more now I guess um I went to the
post office once and that was hard I
went to Urgent Care and I thought my
legs were going to give out from under
me um cuz I had to stand there the
entire time after walking in you know I
kept just looking back at the chair and
just praying that I could just make it
another second until she was done with
me you know
um I I can't even I couldn't even
probably go check the mail right now
between you know the the growth I have
in my FAA so not my apron but my pelvic
region did she say my FAA is she talking
about apron is she talking about her
belly apron FAA oh those are actual body
parts well FAA is what we I don't think
it's a a no apron's a body part well a
apron I I mean where you put an apron is
I believe what what it is like so what
she talk about the belly well it's not a
body part like you don't have an apron
right and you don't have a FAA so it's
an over it's what we call parts of the
bodies that are over developed look it
up so like let's say if you were like
super would you just call it a
Coke like I'm not even trying to be you
see what the I got to work here no
no no no you see what the I got to
work with it's not to make I genuinely
don't know this lingo when she said an
apron she said it casually so she
actually means her body fat like looks
like apron yes cuz it it
hangs does it hang down low does it
touch it I don't watch this content I
don't know I don't watch it either whoa
that is
wild that is wild this kind of lingo
apron
belly what cause an apron belly okay let
me just keep watching this is crazy M
yeah I did not
know how to like I know about diaper
booty I don't think that's a ter D no
that think I don't think that's
something I know what you're talking
about and what you you know some people
got diaper booty I don't think that's
that I don't think that's a that's
something thing no but a okay a Cod I
don't sh I got to lift my apron I was
like I I didn't know okay it's like when
you work in the service industry and you
have to put an
apron it's really that they have an
apron you need to wash right you have to
lift that up got at some point
it's not everybody that have a footall
it's not everybody that belly a foa is
normal I the terminology is just crazy
to me it's like somebody saying y listen
it's hard for me to walk around in my
space suit like that's a
lot the visual you never heard foa no
it's about 30 40 lbs now um I go in
January to see what it is because
apparently um there has been a big
misunderstanding where my doctor thought
I was having issues with my apron but no
it is the growth below that that I have
to physically Al move when I walk
anytime I roll or move or anything I
have to adjust it um and g g game game
so you have yeah let
me so so so this is what this what
happen she got she got an apron this
what happened she pregnant but she not
really pregnant with a baby she pregnant
with a grow no no cuz when you're
pregnant it's right here when you have a
an apron is because it's on the legs
okay so the thing that happened is that
you're not just lifting you know when
you have to go up the stairs
andair you become tired but whenever she
she lift her legs up she has to lift the
weight the apron the apron so her her
leg pushes up what's the growth that's
the apron that's a growth no she said
under the apron there's a growth that's
the foa no she said under the apron
there's a growth
foa apron
foa foa is this is the is the is is this
so the belly is the apron a apron belly
is a belly that is doing this but the
FAA is under is under so that the growth
under her coochie belly if you if you
will does obesity come with a
manual this guy it comes with a manual
and he makes the best
tacos that is wild there's a well-known
activist professor of fat studies Dr Cat
PA say who questioned the links between
weight and health lost her life at age
42 hi my name is cat and I'm usually the
fattest person in the room join me on my
fat positive radio show friend of
Maryland where we talk fat politics
scholarship identity culture and
activism with fat people from around the
world the science isn't actually as
clear-cut as we like to believe and
there's not really quite a consensus yet
about the real relationship between
weight and health obese people and even
morbidly obese people have just as good
of health or sometimes even better
health than people who are in the
healthy weight
range I mean that was your job to study
it and you question whether there was a
real link and you died for
it um so do you have a sort of um sound
bite response to people who just really
firmly hold that position of like yeah
but everyone knows fat is unhealthy so
it's right for them to start from that
assumption point I mean I hope it's
obvious to our audience that that's not
the position we hold here at NAFA but we
we know that there are folks all over
the world in all different areas and
disciplines who do hold that and what's
your sort of like quick dismissal of
that I mean honestly rolling my eyes and
walking away like
I reasonable reasonable yeah and to be
really honest tiger it's like I don't
like in my own kind of activism and
scholarship and stuff I actually don't
do work around trying to unpack the
myths around fatness and health anymore
uh because I kind of finally realized
that there wasn't really a point um most
people aren't really actually interested
in in being educated around it um and I
I kind of came to view that more as
another form of respectability politics
um you know the idea that fat people are
only worth Liberation or you know only
worth full Humanity if in fact we're not
unhealthy or something just you know is
isn't a use ful or or helpful kind of
mean so I don't tend to engage uh with
those kinds of questions
anymore that totally makes sense um I
think that um people were so freaked out
about what they didn't know about Corona
virus that they were looking for any
information that sort of floated their
way and um and I think uh a lot of us
are not as skilled at being able to look
at the research and say like we might
look at it with skepticism but we're not
as skilled that being able to take it
apart so walk us through a little bit of
that how you and your colleagues take
that kind of research apart and um and
then when one of the first sort of
friends of friends of their family died
and it was like oh we're so surprised
that this guy died but you know he was
overweight so and and there's this this
way that um that that just gets used as
a like oh okay so then it's not tragic
that he died like are we shouldn't we
still be worried about that don't you
think there are still people who cared
about him and want him to be alive and
it's like it is you know as I said
earlier almost like that shrug um but
and I mean we could see that even more
clearly with like elderly people and
people with disabilities so um I'm
originally from Texas and it was the
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
who actually said that grandparents
should be willing to sacrifice
themselves so they don't ruin the the
economy for their grandchildren like you
know we um you know the Unholy Trinity
of why we can't have nice things white
supremacy patriarchy and capitalism have
very much created a culture where you
know people that are seen as less
contributing or as more of a burden uh
to society we you know that oh well
they're Expendable and so that's of
course you know fat people old people
anyone with a disability anyone with a
chronic illness poor people um you know
it's um and yeah the result is that uh
fat people
die I actually don't entirely disagree
with her that we treat people who are
less useful to society as a bit uh
disposable be elderly
disabled singer dismissed the whole idea
of like Health at every s is kind of
nonsense and then her just kind of
brushing that off was a bit alarming and
the fact that she died shortly
afterwards from a heart attack
um it was actually unrelated what was
the heart attack and her
weight sorry oh but this is what I'll
say yeah people definitely do do that I
think
um when with older people I kind of get
it cuz you know you've lived a longer
life and so it's like if an older person
dies versus a younger person it's
obviously more less tragic right you've
lived 70 or 80 or 90 years like you know
like I'm not going to mourn for
grandparents the same way I'm going to
mourn for grandchildren like I think
most people would feel those two things
are drastically different because you
haven't lived a life with people who are
obese I you know the mindset I suppose
is like people are eating away at their
life and they're not willing to make the
changes or they haven't been successful
in making the changes so it's like if
they die makes a bit more sense doesn't
make it right or a virtue but it makes
it understandable I guess it's just not
something that I think is a great thing
and I also say a lot of people are
taking this opportunity just dunk on the
dead people and be like oh yeah
whatever to me that's a wrong attitude
you know celebrating this kind of stuff
or whatever it is it's like yeah some
people are very hard-headed and some
people are n negative in terms of how
they influence other people but
celebrating their death in this way is
never something I think we should ever
encourage if you have empathy for these
people and you understand they're
suffering and many of them are trying to
make a change and they are making a
change it's just slow or you know
they're having setbacks often the last
thing that helps them is like you being
there being alive man you die it's
not helpful you're doing that for your
own ego and your own selfish desire to
be like yeah that's what you deserve but
is that really an empathetic thing to do
is that even kind or helpful to the
people the truth is this obese person
could be someone in your
family would you you be happy if those
people died and didn't have a chance at
redeeming themselves or fixing their
issues would you really be happy no but
here you are cackling and celebrating
when it's somebody from a different
family that to me seems a bit heartless
so I don't know this whole topic is just
sad to me I I don't know how people come
at it and and then they're gleeful and
they're happy about these things
happening to me just it always STS who
is plenty people plenty people online
are celebrating they laugh at oh yeah
see is what happened you I get the
whole idea of consequences to your
action you know a certain level of
accountability sure it's not just
entirely individual Choice a huge part
of it is I agree but another part of it
is like we talked the societal factors
that influenc it right it's like we
don't make being healthy the most
easiest choice in a lot of places we
don't make walking an accessible tool in
a lot of places in North America we
don't get people access to public
transport that's effective for people to
get around you just tell people
essentially like yo either you gym or
you start running like in a lot of
places in the world a lot of people are
healthy and they never go to the gym or
run you wonder why cuz walking is an
option cuz taking public transport
natural forms of exercise that are very
effective as an option we don't also
have a thing where our foods are just
constantly lated with all kinds of
things and preservatives that are going
to make you more obese for no reason it
even affects people who are not obese
and makes them unhealthier too so we
have Foods in our industry that works
actively against us to keep us from
being healthy you know there's a lot of
different things that make us complicit
in the fact that other people are making
these poor choices and getting to the
point where they're dying from obesity
or whatever it is yeah it's not just
entirely think like oh individuals are
here's something that's up some
people are born into families that just
them like losing weight okay a lot
of people come back from it when you
start off as a kid and you're morbidly
obese you know how hard it is to come
back from that and study after study
shows when you're rais in it the odds of
you coming out of it are extremely slim
all our family are have big bones no
you've been eating crap since well your
grandma gave you crap like Mama give
crap to the kids and it's been crap
giving from generations to Generation
generation but I don't necess blame
y'all because the food thing in the
states is weird sometimes finding
someplace with healthy food is
weird very weird even from us whenever
we go uh wherever we go um in the states
and stuff like that and we have like an
Airbnb
and healthy food around sometimes is
tough to find super tough very difficult
and then if you want to get it you
either delivery or you got to drive
there so and you going to be driving for
a minute yeah so it it's like this food
situation is weird and it's even worse
if you're poor if you're poor it's like
they make legislation for you to eat
crap so you've already got diabetes
you're not even an adult kid oh it's
written somewhere in your agenda like
it's for later for you yeah before your
graduation you get two certific
it's crazy and an epip pan hands some
insulin like come on like Society
speaking I think we don't engineer
things in a way that's thoughtful or
considerate or engaging in practices
that are most healthy for people so
again that's why I don't look at this
issue as a simple like well you ate it
so you it's like man yo starting in
your 20s at 400 lbs and you've never
really learned to eat differently and
you guys are just cackling when these
people pass away like
their families them
generationally they got the
setback is real some of y'all families
set you back yep mentally and physically
yep that's real yep so all this to say I
understand and it's okay to say people
need to be accountable for what they're
doing absolutely that's a huge part of
this conversation I never take away from
that but we also have to acknowledge as
Society some of our messaging around
this stuff lacks compassion lacks
consideration and it's generally just
being like well you Ain it you it's
like it's not that simple and if you
really think of creating society that
way then you're not really considering
good Solutions you're not trying to
create environments that are going to be
conducive to you being
successful it ain't weird that we live
in a world where it's cheaper to get
soda than it is to get water mhm it's
crazy it's cheaper to get like any snack
with like every sugar you can want and
and like you get it in bulk and it's
feeling versus getting vegetables like
that that is a twisted Society man there
a fact just the fact that like there's
more water than land on this Earth but
water is Hell expensive it doesn't feel
like we set up so people can be
healthy and that to me for a society
that wants supposedly healthy people
seem so backwards it doesn't feel that
way they don't they don't so many of the
people in the food Lobby just seem to be
able to buy their way into the best spot
to be advertising to our kids to eat the
most sugar Laden food and convince him
it's somehow healthy hey the cereal
industry was one of the weirdest ones
for me I we grew up on it and it's like
the cereal is amazing for you you need
to get all your grains in and all this
other you just come to find out
later they were just stuffing us and
getting us addicted to this sugar
like the the the remember when
you used to come back home after after
school yeah advertisement was crazy y
the advertisement was crazy y targeted
to kids fruit rollups fruit gushers all
the sweet stuff yep when you go when you
go to the grocery store where's the
where's the where the the the cereals
boom that level with the flashy collars
and two can Sam Captain Crunch count
shakula all those characters that are
nah man this is weird yeah is weird I
hate these movements that make fatness
like super accepted and wonderful
looking or whatever the it is all
that person is saying yeah you
glorifying OB City I hate that stuff but
if You' ask me what do I really think is
causing a lot of this do I think it's
the food industry their lobbying power
do I think it's like the access to good
good regular physical fitness in the
form of walking public transport biking
stuff like that or fat acceptance I'm
always going to say it's the other one
the fat acceptance I think is just like
a a symptom of other issues the first
one seems to be like the bigger issue to
me I think there's something in the
message the root of the message there's
something true about that and then it
got out of hand um um when people that
are considered bigger uh and I'm talking
about not like next to the extreme but
some people that are they have a little
bit more P pounds than the the norm or
what is considered normal and whenever
they go to the doctor the doctors
sometimes doctors because they are
because they have a lot of jobs to do
sometimes they want to take shortcuts
and they're not necess going to properly
diagnose certain people or certain
things and they're going to link it to
Fat immediately they're going to be like
H lose some weight and you're going to
be fine or the same that sometimes some
women they have problems and doctors
because they have again they're busy
they're going to be like ah take the
pill uh you have this problem take the
pill Ando endometriosis take the pill
you have this pill that take like they
they do
not they do not further their researches
especially and the same thing happen
when they see someone and it's bigger
they just go like man it's because
you're fat lose a couple of f pounds and
you're you're going to be right and I
think that message is important for the
um the Health Community to maybe react
better or maybe do a little bit of
researches but at the end of the day at
the end of the day there is a
correlation with being obese and certain
illnesses I want to say there's not just
a correlation there's also a huge
causation Factor yes yes all that so I
think both of those those messages can
coexist yes the doctors need to do
better and they need to not be lazy at
some point
to it's like if I walk in and based of
on me being black they be like stop
eating fried chicken well I'm vegan
sir what is a bit of of the same thing
when they see fat they're like man
but there's also that there's also when
when the more the older you get the more
difficult it
is with that extra pound the extra that
extra weight
it is more difficult to move around to
to be solid on your feet to not to not
be exhausted it is it is it it is so I
want to say what you were saying about
the doctor stuff go ahead I get what
you're saying but you have to understand
doctors can't just treat your problem
because sometimes finding the solution
to a problem is not a matter of test
it's a matter of process of elimination
and the truth is a lot of people's
issues when it comes to their health are
linked to their daily choices in regards
to food and stuff like that so you know
it's hard to figure out like yo is the
reason this person's huffing and puffing
is it because they have a respiratory
disease or is that's like very rare or
hard to tr find out about or is it
because they're extremely obese and vast
majority of the time is going to be one
over the other and doing the test and
the whole thing for the other child it's
like yo listen you haven't done the bare
minimum to at least root out a lot of
your own issues it's like yeah it's
called troubleshooting yes you just
going to eliminate the thing that is it
might not be that but I'm going to
eliminate the thing that is easiest to
eliminate before I go deep I'm going the
one that's going to be more cost cost
effective it's called troubleshooting
that's what they do they do
troubleshooting that's why whenever you
have a wash and dryer and you open the
lid right it's written uh if you have
issues is your thing plugged in before
you call us and then you do a whole
bunch of and then you you clog the
lines and this and that whatever is is
is it plugged in that's why it's written
that you you're thinking oh well it's
stupid well some people sometimes don't
think about it if it's written because
there's a reason so yes or yes you're
right okay so that's it's
troubleshooting that's the doctors are
doing the same thing yeah so I 100% yes
I agree with that I agree with that so
it's not only it's not only the fact
that they're lazy but also we got a
troubleshoot here so let's eliminate
what's the best thing I understand but
both of them can coexist and I can
understand how you feel and being a
black person walking in an an office of
the doctor there are some conditions
that are more prevalent in being black
than being white all right black people
people we are more prone to have flat
foot we are more prone to have high
blood pressure we have more prone to
have uh cholesterol we are more diabetes
like certain cancers at an earlier age
too absolutely you know when you see the
actor from Black Panther him getting
that I think it was colon colon cancer
at his age very rare for people
generally but the truth is for black
folks you're actually supposed to get
tested four to five years before the
rest of the population because your odds
are get to get much earlier or higher
same thing with prostate so yeah no it's
not cuz I'm black that I'm nestly no
you're right but there are some factors
there are some things that are there all
right
that it is what it is um so I looked at
this girl's um Tik Tok and it's just her
struggling to lose weight and she
documents things and she talks candidly
you know I think it's a re Return of the
balance because the health thing was so
toxic at some point and using some crazy
tactics and you
know it was really crazy and really
unhealthy that they went the other route
it's just the the the the balance going
on the other side you know what I mean
yeah y so I think that's what it is for
now right well let's know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from
you